c'est demain que commenceront les
défilés haute couture en avant-première
giorgio armani lé célèbre couturier
italien ouvre le bal cette année il a
choisi de délaisser milan pour parier
capitale de la couture dans les
coulisses estelle cola et olivier robert
giorgio armani c'est lui silhouette
athlétique crinière argentée tantôt
styliste tantôt pdg tantôt gourou en
trente ans il est devenu le créateur le
plus riche du monde et pour cause
l'homme ne connaît pas les chèques un
cas d'école pour certains une énigme
pour d'autres du et 70 ans
tout le monde le sait et il n'ya pas
l'interview à la fin de laquelle je ne
me sens pas faire le demande mais
maintenant qu'est ce que vous allez
faire ce qu'il va faire par exemple
présenté sa première collection haute
couture lui l'homme du prêt-à-porter
alors pour gagner ce nouveau challenge
cette nuit confiance il est déjà sa
petite idée en tête il est de faire en
couture qui n'existaient pas et surtout
des consuls est par exemple que même si
la femme à la recherche et fait
attention aux prix c'est un modèle
j'aimais vous que portait la casquette
comme ça on sable comme s'il s'agit d'un
grimpeur pas trop pris au sérieux
mes patrons 5 europe très sérieuse et
côté opportune cette délicieuse
insouciance cache un verre plat câble
perfectionniste son truc
cinq collections différentes à chaque
client son modèle du jeans à la robe du
soir 200 euros à 65000 son talent
surtout n'oublier personne création
fabrication distribution l'homme
contrôler le moindre rouages et c'est
sûrement ça la clé de sa réussite
une réussite qui pèse aujourd'hui 3
milliards d'euros